lady I feel peaceful and quiet surprise
yes why yes she she asked me had put the
good question after all the quails I had
to meet and I am responsible myself in a
good way not only in a bad way
I I was astonished yes it was very cool
address by the Swedish Academy this kind
of decision and I'm really this is a
these are good people
you want called for the abolition of the
Nobel so she she told if he put me the
same question but I don't speak your
limit yeah you have respect for it and
you're happy that you want it does it
mean something one nice notice I'm not
the winner you know no I trust my work
but I'm not my nature is not the nature
of a winner but always they say he won
the Nobel Prize I did I don't like this
this expression meaning of identity user
yeah it's a kind of a strange kind of
freedom I don't know a freedom at if I
which is not the truth as if I were
cognition I don't need I think is right
you are born as a guilty person and now
today perhaps in the evening it will
change today for this hour I don't
forget I feel free but that's at six
o'clock in the evening I will become
again guilty
like you're going to celebrate how are
you going to so I don't know how to talk
how to do it I would like to drink I
didn't eat anything today I didn't know
about what you see what this is name
polish writer I don't know her limit in
Christ man your questions are not very
soupy except Allah I I knew I was young
a young guy like like the song by ray
Davis from the kinks perhaps you know
him and there is a there's a sentence or
phrase in it I like a lot
this sentence is there is too much on my
mind and this don't to put many
questions about money now